>> Nafiza: Technology, I technically
use it from the moment I wake up,
because my cell phone
is my alarm clock.
Like my iPod is in my pocket
while I walk to school.
Oh, and I have to check
Facebook when I get home.
My favorite games are like
racing games and fighting games.
I spend a lot of time on Dance
Dance Revolution, which is awesome.
And this is my avatar as
she typically will look.
And I think initially, when
everyone goes into Second Life,
they try to make their
avatar look like themselves,
like especially facial features
wise, but I like the ocean very much.
I thought I'd have a very
oceanic kind of eye color,
so I thought that was
a good way, you know,
to have my eye representative of me.
>>Nafiza has been amazing.
I met Nafiza two years ago when she
joined our virtual video project,
which is a program which the
youth make animated movies
about global issues.
>>Video: He's wearing a Dalai
Lama necklace, you're suspended!
>>Barry: So for example, one project
might mean that they build something
in Second Life, but then
they'll photograph it and move it
up to Flickr and then bring it from
Flickr into a digital comic program,
output that as a PDF, and then put
it up in a blog entry on the blog.
So the virtual becomes the
central place for gathering
and to organize what
they're learning,
but it's all about interconnecting
all these different mediums together
as part of a seamless
educational experience.
>>Student: Currently I'm working on
getting the movie down to one minute,
trying to put the scenes
together, 'cause there's a--
>>Tabitha: Now the exciting part
about their film making of that,
they're not using real life cameras.
They're using everything virtual.
So they're using Second Life,
which is a virtual community,
as a platform to learn.
They're learning about computers
and all the software embedded
and they're learning to
work with each other.
>>Nafiza: -- and after he notices
that he can't get equal access
to education in China, he
decides to leave with his mother--
>>The virtual video project
we're doing is injustices
in the educational system.
And we divided them into the
United States, Brazil and Tibet.
So each individual group is going to
focus on capturing a one minute film
on the struggle one child
has when they're trying
to attain higher education.
>>Video: At this rate, we can't
afford to keep you in school,
The tuition is already too
expensive for us Tibetans.
>>Video: It's just not fair.
>>Nafiza: I am helping a lot of
the students with little things
like how do you turn the camera,
how do you edit this,
how do you cut this?
So I have taken on a more
leadership role than I did last year
when I was also a student learning.
>>Barry: Every year,
something new is coming out,
and then something new is replacing
something else, and they grow
and they expand and they reconnect,
That's gonna keep happening
over their lives, and what we
need youth to be able to do
to be digitally literate, is
to be able to not just know how
to use the tools that are
currently in their lives,
but how they can take advantage of
the latest tools when they come out,
teach themselves and figure out how
to apply them for their education
or for being civically engaged.
>>Nafiza: There's just so many topics
and world issues going on out there,
it's hard to choose one--
>>Last year I was judging the Games
for Change contest, and through that,
I got to know about a
lot of different games,
like Karma Tycoon.com
and Darfur is Dying,
And they're basically games
based on the different struggles
that are going on, and you
know, what's going on in Darfur,
it's a very complicated issue,
it's not just ethnicity, it's also,
you know, border issues, so it's
a really good way to, you know,
introduce little kids to the topic
and give them a touch of reality.
Let's see.
>>Barry: Nafiza very quickly
became one of the young people
in the program that people
look to for advice and support,
We're able to see her confidence
of her ability, to use the program
as a space for her to
not just do great things
by making an amazing movie that's
been seen by over 10,000 people,
but take up a role amongst her
peers and within the society
where she can see herself
as a leader.
>>Nafiza: My iPod is like my entire
life, especially in the summer,
and whenever it dies
it's like, recharge,
listen to it while it's charging,
unplug, walk around, do something,
listen to the iPod, But, you know,
I have to start relying on something
that has better battery life, Yeah.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org